Narrator:
Princeton University's Program in Dance is
honored to welcome the internationally acclaimed
Narrator:
director and choreographer of the Bill T.
Jones/Arnie Zane dance company and 2010
Narrator:
Kennedy Center honors recipient Bill T. Jones
to the Lewis Center for the Arts on Tuesday, Jan. 18.
Narrator:
Jones will discuss the origin and evolution
of "Continuous Replay," a seminal dance work
Narrator:
that was originally choreographed as a solo
by Mr. Jones's late partner, Arnie Zane, in
Narrator:
1978 and will be performed as a group work
by Princeton University students at the Spring
Narrator:
Dance Festival in February.
In a recent interview conducted in Venice,
Italy, Mr. Jones reflects on time past and
Narrator:
present, expressing that much has changed
since he co-founded the Bill T. Jones/Arnie
Narrator:
Zane Dance Company 28 years ago, around the
same time that "Continuous Replay" was first created.
Bill T. Jones:
The company is now 28 years old. There's nobody
in my world who remembers when the company started.
Bill T. Jones:
There's no one, save the lighting
designer, Robert Wierzel, who remembers Arnie Zane...
Bill T. Jones:
who knew him. So, this passage of
time is very real.
Bill T. Jones:
This memory that as time goes on becomes my memory,
as opposed to the group memory.
Bill T. Jones:
But I have to make my peace with the fact
that everything is changing, and it changes
rapidly... quickly. Sometimes, it makes me very anxious.
Bill T. Jones:
Sometimes, it makes me sad. And sometimes, it's exhilarating.
Like a parent with a child, the child is going to learn
as they learn. The parent has to enjoy that
Bill T. Jones:
as opposed to being frightened by it. I am
trying to enjoy it -- this change, this rapid
Bill T. Jones:
change, new personalities, new problems --
I'm trying to enjoy it, the change.
Narrator:
Excerpts from "Continuous Replay" were staged
on Princeton University students, shown here
in rehearsal.
Narrator:
Bill T. Jones's choreography will be performed
during the Spring Dance Festival at the Berlind
Narrator:
Theatre on Feb. 18-20, 2011.
For ticket information, call University Ticketing
at (609) 258-9220.